him and the soldiers he stood with Tim
O'Brien The Things They Carried tonight
at 9 p.m. Eastern on book TV on c-span 2
[Music]
author Robert Kaplan traveled to seven
nations with an American military
presence there he visited with elite
units on the front lines Imperial grunts
is his examination of the differences
between those shaping foreign policy at
home and those enacting the policies
abroad this talk from the American
Enterprise Institute in Washington is an
hour in 10 minutes it's very difficult
to classify Robert Kaplan he might be
called the military man's favorite
travel writer he might be called a
serious strategic thinker who likes to
look at matters from the ground level up
and not just from up he would probably
say in an ivory tower looking down I
would say that he is in the greatest
tradition of military journalists
somebody who travels around with
warriors with soldiers who understands
the work that they do on a day to day
basis and who has made a specialty of
living in uncomfortable places and
looking at the work that our military
does that is too frequently ignored he
is a New Englander he went to the
University of Connecticut he has been a
correspondent for the Atlantic Monthly
for 20 years and has often written for
other journals and newspapers as well
often on military subjects off and on
sometimes on academic subjects as well
he has written 11 books his first
appeared in 1988 surrender or starve
travels in Ethiopia Sudan Somalia and
Eritrea
other notable recent works have been
soldiers of God with Islamic warriors in
Afghanistan and Pakistan which was
recently reissued and the one before the
one he'll be speaking about tonight
warrior politics why leadership demands
a pagan ethos which was a New York Times
notable book of the year his newest work
Imperial grunts the American military on
the ground is the first of a projected
number of books and they're not just
projected he's actually not just on a
book tours these days but well along
into the second volume that is following
the work of the American military at the
farthest extremes of the globe this book
is if you if you eliminate diet and
exercise books it's very high on the
effective New York Times a serious book
a best-seller list it has been very
widely reviewed it has been a hot
subject of discussion and I must say of
great admiration around our corridors in
at AEI
I've been trying hard to get Bob to
speak at AEI for many years now I
usually get an email that is bounced
three times around since he sent it from
a laptop someplace in and well where was
the last time but that's right or from
Mongolia or wherever places whose whose
stories and whose importance to America
I is recounted in this wonderful book
which he will be talking about and
talking about some other things as well
I'm sure in his lecture which is
entitled the US military keystone of
World Order please give a warm welcome
to Robert Kaplan
[Applause]
thank thanks Chris and AEI for that very
gracious welcome after every few trips
with the military I come back here every
year and I'm always welcome and I'm
always grateful for it this book is
about personalities it's about people
individuals what I've tried to do in
this book is to be more of an
old-fashioned travel writer and less of
a contemporary hard news journalist what
that actually means is that I don't ask
people direct questions I don't put a
microphone in front of their faces I
don't take out my notebook when I'm
introduced to them I go into a barracks
with sergeants and corporals and
sometimes we'll spend a week or more
before taking out my notebook I befriend
people and reveal them to the reader as
they reveal themselves to me it's and
and and I reveal them on their own terms
what I try to do is without without
books like these these people wouldn't
have a voice and who are these people
somebody like major robert e lee jr. of
mobile an alabama who's named his son
Stonewall but on the other hand spent a
year as a church based volunteer in a
poor african-american section of Wichita
Kansas where he learned as he told me in
the southern Philippines where he was
his Special Forces Green Beret that for
the that he realized that folks are just
folks and and that's where I began to
learn that you don't stereotype people
you don't stereotype southerners in
uniform you don't stereotype
evangelicals you get to know them on a
personal basis and as I as I started
this journey what I realized was I was
less of a military correspondent then
somebody like even Studs Terkel doing
the working man or Barbara Ehrenreich do
you know embedding with minimum wage
laborers for nickel and dimed except the
working people I was with happen to wear
unit
and they happen to get shot at from time
to time and mentality x' before I get
into the meat of this talk which will
take me beyond the book into what I
learned over the past four years being
embedded six months out of every twelve
take someone like Mike Neal from the
southside of Chicago
eighteen-year-old kid lance corporal in
the Marines I was with him in El garma a
town near Fallujah we were surrounded by
enemy mortar and RPG fire the fire fight
lasted a half an hour he didn't take out
his he didn't shoot once his gun stay
dry the entire time and when he and when
I asked him afterwards why he said
because I did not have a clear shot with
too many civilians around that's 99
percent of US Marines and soldiers and
in Iraq in the Middle East one of the
most amazing things I think the thing
that gave me the greatest privilege in
my professional life was to be with
Marines during a slow advance during the
Battle of Fallujah a slow foot advance
into the heart of close quarters combat
where as soon as as soon as insurgent
fire started I saw tough
boisterous eighteen and nineteen year
olds become calculating quiet and
technical forty year olds not shooting
wildly looking for a shot here and there
whenever they could often they couldn't
and it was that maturity what you saw
all the training kicked in in seconds
almost that would yet that I felt I was
so privileged to witness or Keith pay
Special Forces Green Beret from Ann
Arbor Michigan in the southern
Philippines was job was treating
Filipino peasants during a medical
exercise children were dying of
rehydration and he figured out that he
could save their lives by injecting them
with Gatorade jeremy kempner another
Marine Lance Corporal I met in Djibouti
on his way to Iraq I had seen his
step-grandfather killed in Colombia
about nine months before his stepfather
was a whizz it was a private contra
a Bronze Star winner in Vietnam and to
it and then to see this and then to meet
his grandson it one of the that one of
the things that I learned is that we
live in a very complex society where we
all separate out into subgroups lawyers
date and marry lawyers journalists the
same thing and the military is becoming
its own caste of subgroup we're sons
grandsons fathers join the service they
up they married people in the service
etc or Kevin Holliday an evangelical
Christian from northern Florida who grew
a beard learned push to rub his beard up
against Afghan elders and became an area
expert on on on push tune culture on the
afghan-pakistan border lots of people
like this who were very surprising
personalities and who who have basically
spent the last few years with while
elites while people like us while elites
debate grand issues in general terms in
new york washington wherever there is a
whole class of people working class
lower middle class who are a pro who are
applying policy on their own each the
cultural repository of America's
experience with freedom generally
oblivious to far away discussions let me
give you an example of how this works
there have been a lot of discussions
about the Afghan army how soon we should
stand it up how soon we should close
down warlords own militias and other
tribal and ethnic Milaap militias well
when you get to Afghanistan you find a
staff sergeant consulting with a major
or a captain deciding what to do with
the local militia in each area of
Afghanistan requires a different policy
towards the local militia and these
people are making the decision based on
the particular the petition in each area
the specific each area has a different
micro policy it personalities of the
militiamen are involved tribal
animosities are involved and this is
where it gets quite
it's very practical and technical and
we're general discussions far away it
can serve only in the Vegas guidelines
that doesn't mean they listen they don't
listen to civilians however a scholar
writes a very serious thesis at one of
the war colleges that has applied that
has applied common sensical value they
find out about it what did I learn
during this whole period first of all
let me say that the people I'm talking
about on any given week are deployed in
68 70 countries around the world they're
not secret deployments it's just that we
don't hear about them because they're
not covered and that's why in this book
I start out in Yemen I go to Colombia I
go to Mongolia to Kenya to Somalia to
other to Eritrea
to the Philippines and only at the end
wind up in Afghanistan and Iraq
what would the thing what were the
bullet points that I learned first of
all in this book I concentrated on the
law on the noncommissioned officer corps
the sergeants and the corporals and the
warrant officers and middle level
commissioned officers captain's
lieutenants etc why did I do that
because I found that there were so many
books being written about Colonels and
generals and others that I felt
something was desperately required about
the middle and lower ranks and how they
thought about tactical issues and
occasionally big issues let me say first
the first lesson I learned is that the
future belongs to the sergeant's why do
I say this because the nature of war is
changing the old battlefield was it was
small in size but had large numbers of
troops packed inside it that was the
essence of mass infantry war mass
infantry war is not over that's why we
can't disband or the Regular Army or any
such thing we could have a mass infantry
war in Korea next year or the year after
but generally speaking the battlefield
is getting larger its emptying out and
becoming more dispersed and you have
small clusters of in
vigils hunting down are dealing with
other small clusters of combatants over
vast deserts jungles third-world cities
and slums whether it's New Orleans
whether it's whether it's Peshawar and
Afghanistan whether it's the Iraqi
desert killing the enemy is easy it's
finding him that's difficult
and once you're dealing in the realm of
small units that in the level of the
platoon the team or the squad even
that's when you're in the realm of the
generic sergeant or even the Lance
Corporal or the captain or the
lieutenant obviously I'm using sergeant
in a very general term we have a very
stereotyped stereotypical vision of
noncommissioned officers still we have
not had a draft for a third of a century
and many of us still think when we hear
the word sergeant we think of old
television series from the 1950s and
1960s like sergeant bilko or Gomer Pyle
or something like that
someone who's screaming over a recruits
head while he's doing push-ups um let me
tell you about a master sir Green Beret
Master Sergeant who I was with in
Algeria this summer
that's right Algeria I had a typical
summer with the US military 11 Green
Berets first US military mission to
Algeria since Operation Torch of
November 1942 southern Algeria 11 Green
Berets come to train with a company that
is about a hundred and fifty Algerian
Special Forces troops Algeria has gone
has become one of the most friendly
countries to the u.s. in the Middle East
after being one of the most radical the
Master Sergeant really the executive
officer who along with a captain Mike
Ghidorah and from the Philippi from the
zoo a graduate of the Citadel the Master
Sergeant the team sergeant was Ken
butcher grew up on a farm in central New
Hampshire was accepted at Dartmouth
decided not to go enlisted in the army
instead he's been in the army about two
decades speaks several exotic languages
can get through paperwork like a
middle-level corporate style manager can
can
deal with with locals in all kinds of
situations he has mentored the cabinet's
of several former Soviet republics on
earthquake and disaster relief he was in
Sierra Leone twice the two times that
country collapsed he was in Liberia when
it collapsed he was in the Congo when it
collapsed he's the go-to man for
humanitarian disasters he'll retire in a
year and go back to managing his
family's farm the family farm is dying
in the United States but half of these
Green Berets I spent the summer with
were from family farms that's another
thing I found every very interesting and
that can be your typical Special Forces
sergeant these days and and he
increasingly has power because we are
powering down two small units and
pushing out decision making to the
farthest edges of the battlefield to
what in corporate terms what the private
sector would call the point of contact
with the customer the customer Bay may
be an insurgent who needs to be killed
it may be a person who needs to have who
needs a water well dug and you know
after a disaster of some sort it may be
a friendly civilian who needs to be
dealt with in a very diplomatic manner
it's where the military ends and
civilians in a non US military begins
and that's why I think that the number
one issue in transformation is NCO
training noncommissioned officer corps
training because as good as it's gotten
it's not good enough let me give you an
example with the Marines often you will
have a very tense pivotal situation in
an Iraqi town or an Afghan town or in
Fallujah and the and the point of
contact the person making a decision on
the spot could be a corporal four and a
half years into his little enlistment
and may not reenlist that's not an
optimal situation you want it to be a
sergeant or a staff sergeant who's
already on his second enlistment the
difference in experience maturity is
great but you just can't snap your
finger and make that happen because even
a smaller more agile bureaucracy like a
more like the Marine Corps would need to
totally
it's training schedules it's enlistment
schedules it would be it would be a
terrible bureaucratic challenge to just
make this happen quickly but these are
the challenges we face because I believe
increasingly the future is going to be
with noncommissioned officers and what
is the future what I've learned is that
the future is fluidity let me repeat
that word fluidity we make false
distinctions between domestic operations
like New Orleans and foreign ones like
Afghanistan between traditional combat
operations like Fallujah and traditional
disaster relief operations like the
northwest tip of Sumatra after the
Indonesian tsunami when US Marines and
sailors provided the bulk of the relief
aid and USS Abraham Lincoln pumped
hundreds of millions of gallons of fresh
water ashore as much as it could because
the sailors went weeks without showers
in order to up that amount as much as
possible why do I consider those false
distinctions number one because the
difference between disaster and
humanitarian emergency relief is getting
narrower because whether it's a disaster
operation like the tsunami or a
hurricane in New Orleans or it's getting
inside Fallujah it's about several
things it's about access it's about
quick insertion it's about establishing
security on the ground the moment you
hit the ground so you can get relief
supplies or or get your supplies moving
why security because even in New Orleans
even in a well governed society after a
major natural event climatic or seismic
you will have security systems
completely break down and be swept away
along with everything else so you were
in the same situation in the United
States or somewhere in Indonesia as you
are in the poorest most an ARCA country
also there's a saying in the military
that amateurs discuss tactics and
strategy and professionals discuss
logistics and disaster relief operations
are about three things logistics
logistics logistics
also the US military has the airlift and
the sea lift from major natural
disasters we live in a media age an age
of global media that's increasing and
increasingly intense and in that age
when you have a major natural
catastrophe there is a drumroll a roar
you know a roar from people saying do
something do it fast no matter who it is
these people need help
and and yes I know the US military may
be an organization with which people
around the world are not particularly
comfortable and yet at the same time
when the tsunami happened when there was
a major catastrophe people said where is
the US military and when they were there
they were very grateful for the relief
that they provided and let me give you
another example of how the difference
between combat and disaster relief is
closing I was embedded for a month on an
arleigh burke-class guided-missile
destroyer the USS been fouled off the
coast of Indonesia now the bend fall
because of a sea swap a crew swap with
the USS higgins the sailors on this ship
had seen combat in Operation Iraqi
Freedom of March 2003 that is their ship
had fired missiles live missiles into
Baghdad in the opening days of the war
they were in combat but it was abstract
to them it was abstract to them and but
in the tsunami
um they saw dead bodies of human beings
women and children you know violently
killed by mother nature if not by human
beings if not by human beings float past
them on the ship and that traumatized
them more than anything they experienced
an operation iraqi freedom for them the
tsunami relief operation was the rite of
passage
not-not-not o if1 and you know that's
just an example of that
I think there's business is going to be
booming and the world is going to see an
increasing use of the US military for
the following reason for the first time
in human history you have large complex
or
populations living on environmentally
seismically and climatically fragile
areas where human beings have never
lived before in history
two-thirds of China lives in a flood
zone the New Madrid fault line along the
Mississippi Valley had major earthquakes
in 1811 1812 you could see the cracks in
the wall in Daniel Boone's house in
eastern Missouri today and this was
before Memphis and st. Louis existed for
all practical purposes we're gonna have
major catastrophes because and you don't
need global warming for it all you need
is the natural variations of climate
climate and seismic activity combined
with continued absolute increases in
urban populations I wrote a piece about
China recently on the cover of the
Atlantic Monthly and how the US military
will be shifting its focus to sort of
contain and constrain to the rise of
Chinese sea sea and land power and in a
kind of a way that that prevents a major
outbreak of hostilities but the irony is
the big irony is that because of this
climatic demographic situation and
because of the global media the first
time large numbers of American troops
may actually be on Chinese soil sometime
in the first half of the 21st century
maybe after a natural catastrophe a
major earthquake or flood or something
in which the roar for relief aid will be
so big that Americans will come in as
part of an international force and
that's why the US military has to be
prepared for surprises for fluidity for
training for one thing and being able to
deploy for something else I believe in
the Iranian earthquake - the US Air
Force got involved in political problems
were for the moment somewhat swept aside
I think that's the future and if you
look at what's been going on in New
Orleans I've been getting emails with
National Guardsmen 19th group Special
Forces with whom I was embedded in
Afghanistan on the Afghan Pakistan
border and they've been sending me
emails from New Orleans where they're
deployed with night-vision goggles m4
assault rifles hunting down packs of
looters sometimes small unit operations
again powered down to the decision
making of a high noncommissioned officer
a Warrant Officer somebody like that and
there's been a phrase coined by the
Marine general Chuck crew Lac which has
become a cliche in policy circles the
strategic corporal and it's true because
under the klieg light of klieg lights of
the global media you want your corporals
as well-trained as possible because this
decisions they can make can have
different real diplomatic consequences
another issue is in demography the rate
at which world population is increasing
is slowing down
rather dramatically we have grain
populations in Europe and elsewhere of
course but what we still have though for
a few more decades is substantial youth
bulges in the 30 or so must most
unstable countries of the world to begin
with so that you and and the sector of
the population that perpetrates
political unrest is usually the same 14
to 29 year old males now this sector of
the population will still be growing in
absolute terms in relative terms in many
cases and again places that are already
unstable and when you merge this with
climatic and other issues you see there
is going to be a lot of military work I
I call it the militarization of
humanitarian relief a and I am NOT
proposing a theory I'm describing what's
already happened if you look at New
Orleans if you look at Indonesia if you
look at many parts of sub-saharan Africa
where civilian relief agencies can't
operate too far behind the capital like
Nazaire where I was two summers ago with
the US Marines let me move on to two
another issue if you wanted to ask me of
all the theaters where I went where was
what was the most interesting in terms
of the future
was it Iraq was it Afghanistan I don't
leave that Iraq is a model for the
future this is nothing no paradigm we're
gonna want to copy invading a country
with hundreds of thousands of troops
bringing in the global media etc whether
you were for the war against it what
we're gonna want to do is the fought
following and it's what we've been doing
it's getting in fast with the fewest
number of people possible because the
smaller and more bare-bones the mission
the more the US taxpayer gets out of it
the less risk there is if it fails the
less political consequences and and and
the future is moral from a tactical
point of view the future is more along
the lines of the Lewis and Clark and
French and Indian Wars than it is World
War one or World War two because this is
what I observed in the Horn of Africa
theater from Djibouti Army Civil Affairs
sends out groups of people usually
reservists often community workers or
policemen and Sevilla in civilian life
and they scour the towns of Eastern
Ethiopia they go to someone they go to
all these countries and errors towns and
villages and they explore they just go
in and they say what do you need do you
need any relief aid you need water
electricity what do you you know how can
we help you and in terms and by
establishing relationships they learn
about the region they learn about the
security problems and often they do
nothing they don't come back but
occasionally they establish a presence
they become relief workers there and
it's nothing secret they're very open
about the fact that they're from the US
military and and one of the things I
learned is is one captain told me off
the kenyan island of la moved by the
kenyan Somali border where I was
embedded with a group of Army civil of
an army civil affairs team he said to me
that he doesn't wear his uniform at the
beginning but he tells everyone he's
from the US Army but once he gets to
know people well and they know him well
by his first name then it's okay for him
to put on his uniform because they see
the individual behind it but even though
they know he's from the army they're
intimidated by the uniform if they don't
if they don't know him
and these are the kinds of decisions
that young officers are making on the
spot all over the world going to Iraq
what I found was where deploy the US
Army set up an organizational structure
with which it was historically
comfortable but not one which was
necessarily custom suited for the task
at hand I called it the Westmoreland
ization of Iraq in a way big Burger King
little America's style bases around
Baghdad with a very very long support
tale and the question became not do we
need more troops but how can we get more
use out of the troops we already have
there the troops on the ground in Iraq
Afghanistan Colombia everywhere when I
asked them tactically speaking what this
reminded them in terms of tactics they
said the Indian War is on the Great
Plains and the American Southwest in the
second half of the 19th century why
several reasons and John Keegan goes on
into this in forts on the plains if you
read Frances Parkman's memoirs from the
mid 19th century because you're dealing
with small clusters of combatants
which require your own small clusters
the u.s. cavalry never powered down
enough it had too many horses too much
too much forage it had a bring too long
a supply trail and support tale the u.s.
cavalry needed mountain men and
pathfinders meaning it needed cultural
and linguistic area experts and there
weren't enough of them and the same
problem we have now and you have young
officers who studied the Indian Wars as
a way to figure out how we got it wrong
how we could deal more humanely with
these populations how we can yet and
what they always come back to is we
don't have enough little native language
speakers on the ground we're producing
them officially but maybe they disappear
in the NSA in Baltimore or somewhere but
when you're on the ground there's a
shortage I have seen whole battalions
immobilized because the trans
wouldn't couldn't show up that day
because he or she was sick and I believe
that the linguistic knowledge situation
in the military will not improve until
exotic languages and knowing them become
part and parcel of the rank promotion
system so that people have a naked
career self-interest to learn foreign
languages in the military has to become
part of the culture like it isn't our
best liberal arts colleges um you cannot
tell a troop after a 10-hour day to go
home and turn on a laptop and and study
grammar on his own because it's good for
his self-improvement you know when he's
falling asleep over the bed you can't do
that with any of us you can't do it with
the military and and so I think that's
the key thing one of the key things that
needs to change another thing is the
people who provide the best help
available there happen to be the people
who are the most overstretched the
National Guard and the reservist because
the National Guard and Reserve is bring
civilian skills to the table like
community policing being able to deal
with groups of teenagers and if you can
deal with groups of male teenagers on
the street that's the key to winning
over a local population it's nothing
that can be taught in two weeks in an
active-duty training course it's it's
almost a gene almost that you have to
learn from years of policing and it
comes with maturity and the guard and
the reserve have it but when you sign up
for a month and you do 11 months your
morale is gonna be quite low I think the
future may not be a draft it may be
making a part-time Reserve and guard
where individuals will sign up for six
months five months get paid commence or
at least six times as much as they're
being paid be able to plan their lives
accordingly in creative ways because I
have met around the world what like what
people call themselves guard bums and
reserve bums and what they are is people
in the reserve of the guard who because
the various life situations want to be
deployed as many months as possible and
they I know one major in the US Air
Force Reserve who basically puts
together humanity
relief trips taking dock reserved air
force reserve doctors around the
third-world giving treatment to children
she puts together the trip she gets the
funding from the military and she's able
to be deployed many months of the year
there's a whole sector of the society
like this that we're not tapping into
and this would be the way to get a lot
more people as I said this first volume
only deals with Army Special Forces and
Marines future volumes will deal with
the Regular Army their point of view the
Navy the Air Force etc I have only met
two kinds of Green Berets and Marines in
front line infantry Marines those who
have been deployed to Iraq and
Afghanistan and those who are pulling
every bureaucratic string to get there
there is no morale problem in this part
of the military finally let me mention
one or two more points and then I'll
wrap it up the media is part of the
battlespace
it yeah it just is you can win the war
in the battlefield you can lose it in
the media I think the Department of
Defense can be a lot more creative in
dealing with the media during Operation
Iraqi Freedom there was one-stop
shopping for embedding your name your
social security number your blood type
etc it's become much more bureaucratic
in many ways people think that I have
special access because I know people up
top in the military the if anyone you
know as my assistant knows it's 20 stop
shopping for me I put together
coalition's for each trip coalition's of
lieutenant Colonel's and majors you
because you have to get the area
commands approval you have to get the
force providers approval you have to get
the battalion commanders approval if
it's the Philippines you need PACOM on
your side you need Special Operations
Command Pacific suck pack and PACOM you
need the battalion commander in-country
you need his boss and if any one of them
just decides not to answer emails you
don't get embedded the whole true the
whole trip falls apart so there's a lot
more that can be done that way because
the very people who would probably would
probably enjoy the experience and and
you know and learn something
that they didn't learn before probably
the very people who don't have many
contacts in the military in terms of in
terms of embedding I know there's been a
lot of discussion about it I would say
that to question it is legitimate to be
obsessed obsessed with it is an example
of class prejudice because embedding
offers the media one of its last
opportunities to have a sustained
meaningful long-term relationship with
working-class people from around the
country away from the coasts and is the
Columbia Journalism Review reported that
the problem with elite journalism is
that it's becoming more and more
confined to a social class that's
dealing more and more with people of its
own socio-economic level and I think
embedding offers an extraordinary
opportunity um you know you know to
finally rediscover America at least
that's what I did um let me wrap up with
this I think that the US military has
the most thankless task its ever had in
its history that is to help provide the
security armature for an emerging global
civilization that the more that
civilization evolves the less thankful
the beneficiaries will be for the
military that helped help bring it about
in the first place why is it providing
the security armature because in almost
every case in almost in so many
deployments that don't get reported on
but they're not secret what the US
military is doing is it's being invited
in by democratic fledgling democracies
to train their troops because you an age
of democratization is an age of military
professionalization you cannot have a
successful democratization without
reforming the military or else that
military will create trouble you have
the US Marines in Georgia training
retraining the Georgian military to
consolidate the gains of the Rose
Revolution you have the u.s. be wherever
wherever Green Berets or Marines are
training troops it's usually a new
democracy across the swath of Africa
this past
Green Berets and Marines fanned out to
train selected units of Africa new
African democracies to provide for a
future pan-african intervention force
for future dar Force um this is all very
quiet but again not because it's secret
I cover these things that I'm the only
journalist often because others simply
don't in bed not because I have any
special privileges here and I think as
new democracies emerge around the world
the rules of engagement will become
increasingly restricted for the US
military because new democracies mean
new local medias and local medias will
not countenance American troops running
around on their soil hunting people down
Iraq and Afghanistan or exceptions
that's why special operations forces are
becoming more unconventional warfare
oriented which means more emphasis on
humanitarian relief linguistic awareness
winning over local populations and less
emphasis compel ative Lian direct action
or historically traditional commando
activities and so I'll end here we can
take questions and answers thank you so
much
[Applause]
that was that was a brilliant and
engrossing talk thank you very much
thank you right one of your most
prescient books was titled the coming
anarchy and in your talk this evening
you give us a good sense of new military
role in this new era but you but your
focus is on of response right the the
growing likelihood of large natural
natural catastrophes is sort of baked in
but I'm interested in your view given
your travels and research of the last
couple of years of how effective this
new style of global policing is in these
very large empty battlefields and
actually discovering ferreting out and
destroying the enemy terrorist cells
networks there's some evidence that
we've had some success but in a world
where a small number of young men can
possess enormous lethality and the
technology of the lethality is getting
more and more widespread it seems to me
the big question is is this gonna work
and and what what are your thoughts and
what's your prognosis alright first of
all our success has been mixed at best
because here's the problem what we're
really doing what the global war on
terrorism really is about on a tactical
level is helping a lot of countries like
the Philippines and Colombia and Yemen
which aren't really countries become
more like countries what do I mean a
typical situation the Philippines Yemen
Colombia is you have a national
government in the highlands or on one
island which maybe controls half the
country or three-quarters or a quarter
quarter of the country and then you have
all these fast buck tropical lowlands or
deserts where the where the government
doesn't have much control and take Yemen
the Yemeni government controlled you
know Sun are the capitals at 7,000 feet
and and yet you have this whole area on
the saudi yemeni border where it's very
hard to control where you have large
al-qaeda infestation and you travel
through this area and you see all these
unemployed young males with guns without
much to do and so what can we do first
of all you cannot reform a national army
forget you that's very hard to do
because armies are reflections of
cultures what you can do though is you
can dramatically and quickly reform a
company or a battalion or two or three
battalions within that army elite
battalions and bring them up to your own
Western technological tactical moral
standards and with those that what those
companies or battalions can do is they
can go out on selected missions they
they may not control the area 24 hours a
day but they can go anywhere anytime and
they basically can reduce we do reduce
the level of we'll call a terrorist
activity or a terror put put pressure on
terrorists but that but that's that's
all they can do because it's variants
becoming increasingly hard for US troops
on their own to operate because if you
have an increasing democratic
environment you know their words we're a
country that promotes democracy but the
more but as democracies take hold rules
of engagement for our military become
increasingly restricted so it becomes a
very very hard Enterprise and it's kind
of like malaria suppression you can take
pills you can keep it down but there is
no cure it's kind of like you know it's
a disease suppression or something like
that you need this amount of activity
just to keep things on a low burner but
that that are you gonna have outright
success no because to me terrorism is
just the form of warfare that our age of
technology allows let me explain that
statement what it means is in the
industrial age was about bigness who is
about big aircraft carriers big tanks
railway grids etc the post-industrial
age is about smallness it's about the
defeat of matter
it's about hiding plastic explosive in
your pocket and this age of technology
we
live-in gives tremendous advantage to
small groups of people to maximize their
power
the image engine soy we turkish NTV
television yes well my question will be
about your earlier work as well in your
groundbreaking article the coming
anarchy in 1994 there was a section
devoted to Turkey and you said that
despite the country's many advantages to
become a large power its future as a
nation-state was bleak because of the
Turkish Kurdish dispute now more than 10
years later and in light of an ongoing
European Union process do you still have
the same feeling that the Turks and
Kurds will strangle each other at some
point or do you think that the EU
process could transform Turkey into
something else
I think it can transform turkey into
something else in that earlier book an
article I also talked about the strong
social mold muscle tone in Turkish slums
and how there were slums that were crime
free because they were because they were
populated by upwardly mobile people and
what I said was because Kurds are
everywhere in Turkey they're not just in
the southeast as a block they're
everywhere and they're in Izmir they're
in Istanbul and getcha condos etc you
can't you know it's not a matter of
federalism what what real democracy in
Turkey means to me is decentralizing the
fun so that all the tax money doesn't
come to Ankara and that it's spent and
decentralized at the local level all
around the country because you know
that's where you'll get true democracy
because you do have a lot of the water
resources not just for Turkey but for
the whole Middle East into areas with
high ethnically kurdish concentrations
so what citizens in Turkey Kurdish or
ethnic Turk will feel poor they'll all
feel part of the system when they feel
them you know the the money from the
government you know the revenues being
dispersed around the country and not
coagulating an anchor
yeah Gordon Baer army and State
Department retired would you address the
competence of the State Department and
its ability to support or frustrate the
kind of military activity sure sure
the military has had an advantage
because of the goldwater-nichols Act you
know Congress does do great things on
occasion from time to time and the
goldwater-nichols Act substantially cut
the cut the rivalry between the services
it created the joint command and with
all their problems they created they
were large it was did that act was it
had a lot to do with the dynamism in the
military now I think the State
Department is still divided up along
cold war line bureaus it needs the
bureaucratic equivalent of the
goldwater-nichols Act I say that one of
the last holistic secretaries of state
we've had who is both very good for the
Foreign Service and paid attention to
management issues and was also very very
very close to the president was George
Shultz and that was about 17 years ago
and what you need is and it's too early
in dr. Rice's tenure to know you need a
secretary of state who will work closely
with Congress you know in terms of
helping out and reforming the State
Department because what I have to tell
you what I see around the world often is
I see yeah again I don't want a
stereotype but I have to say I've seen a
lot of young Foreign Service officers
who are not up to the caliber of decades
ago and I see young captains and
lieutenants who are at a much higher
caliber than they were before
and also so the military it's kind of
like like oil seeping into gaps seeping
into vacuums that are opening up and
this is bad for the military this is bad
for the US government because the only
thing that will help us in the future is
strong interagency cooperation and
that's what Washington is worst at you
know the British had something called a
colonial office and if you break down
the Colonial Office in some ways you
could define it as an interagency office
that combines civilian
and military functions and and and so
the future of the I think that the
future defense and secretaries of state
they have to work together as a dynamic
duo
we can't again have a strong one and a
weak other you know they have to get you
know they have to be working together
their staffs at all levels you need more
people from defense embedded and state
and vice versa curious that your
description of the future of warfare do
you think we have the right budget
priorities in terms of the military the
problem is that all ages are ages of
transformation to some extent and if it
was just a matter of just having putting
more of an emphasis on counterinsurgency
we'd all be geniuses but the fact is the
Pentagon has to focus on other other
challenges like the rising submarine
force of China for instance which is
buying up nuclear-powered submarines
which means they have blue water
imperial ambitions it has to think about
the possibility of a very conventional
conflict in North Korea so it's not just
a matter of we're gonna be more Special
Forces or and it's a matter of like a
gradual transition even the regular US
Army you know has these new Stryker
brigades which is about powering down to
small to smaller units it so we have We
certainly have enough money because I
think the defense budget is three or
four percent of of g-dub GDP which is
smaller than it's been in decades and
that's with the Iraq war maybe the Iraq
war has pushed it up a bit
I don't expect that we'll have a hundred
and forty thousand troops in Iraq in a
year or two from now whether we succeed
or we fail there and so I think that
hump will be gotten over I think we we
have the money but I think the
priorities frankly have to be more
prosaic what are the three big things
that everyone talks about in Iraq now
that we need more of
sappy plates in other words rifle plates
heart you know hardbacks meaning
up-armored Humvees and and blue force
tracker z' which basically you know
track movements or you know within a
20-mile radius that you can put inside a
Humvee you can put inside a Stryker
fighting vehicle now these were not
things that people were talking about
before the Iraq war they are not sexy
big-budget items and yet we've had
shortages of them so I you know III
think there's a lot of benefit when
thinking about procurement to think
about the prosaic items I was at a small
units excellence conference with the
Marines and the Marines were emphasizing
that what's really needed is a more
modular system for Webb gear for rifles
you know to lighten the load because you
have very fit Marines who are running
around soldiers too with so much weight
on their back they're being outrun by on
surgeons with just ak-47s wearing
flip-flops yeah
been Rotenberg at AI you know uh do you
think that I had is sort of a two-part
question do you think that it is
America's central mission in this era to
bring this full body democracy to the
world
that's Part one and Part two given the
publicity about that very thing does
that make you a neoconservative okay
first part I believe every foreign
policy has to have a moral purpose and I
think the moral purpose of our foreign
policy has to be to extend the
boundaries of civil society wherever and
however it can you know in a moderate
basis given our limitations etc but we
shouldn't become too legalistic about
what constitutes civil society it
doesn't necessarily mean free elections
overnight in China for instance it
doesn't mean that for instant mean
saying to King Abdullah of Jordan that
unless you know he becomes totally a
constitutional monarch with no power
within six months or a year that the
u.s. is going to stop its friendship
with them we have terrible we have
terrible dictatorships around the world
not nearly as many as we used to but we
have a lot of gray area situations
monarchies like in Morocco like in
Tunisia like in unknot Tunisia excuse me
like like in Jordan we have semi
constitutional semi parliamentary
systems like in Yemen we have a lot of
these murky in-between situations
Singapore is probably the best example
though it's fairly democratic as long as
we don't become too legalistic about it
I think just saying we want to push out
the boundaries of civil society for
instance you ask a major in the US Army
and Marines working with new Iraqi
governance councils around the country
what he'll tell you here's what he'll
tell you he'll say we work with
new councils we try to strengthen them
but the fact is that tribal elders
sheiks often have the real control they
can bring in a random carjacker who
we're having trouble with the town
council hasn't been around long enough
to have that kind of authority so we
will often go behind the backs of the
town council to work with old-fashioned
leadership that doesn't make these
majors anti-democratic I don't believe
they're just trying to work with the
situation um I I I would call myself a
moderate conservative if I had to define
myself and I think uh you know they're
in there there are neoconservatives who
you know who you know who you know who
would agree with those army majors I
think you know that these things take
time and there are others who might be
more more more fervent about it Nichols
office I'm a student at sighs you make
no secret of the fact in most of your
books that when you spend so much time
with soldiers you can have an admiration
for them yeah so I was wondering if you
could give us the other side to just the
story we're going to read in your book
one of the micro-level decisions that
the soldiers can do better the decision
that micro level decisions are are this
let me tell you what's the the hobby of
all Special Forces soldiers in the
barracks at night is to complain and
when they stop complaining then you know
there's a real morale problem and so
what do they complain about they tend to
be very self-critical
I'm very kind of a perfectionist and
what they complain about tends to
because most of these are training
missions is that they need to work
harder on improving the noncommissioned
officer corps of the of the you know the
developing countries they're working
with because what often is the problem
that they have the most trouble with is
that they you know they get into a
country and the major of the captain of
the other the other military is doing
everything because he can't delegate
decisions to his sergeants and corporals
because they're not well-trained enough
and disciplined enough so a lot of
things
don't get done and so they become very
frustrated and they get frustrated often
because they don't know the language I
make no secret in the book that even
with the Green Berets I haven't been all
that impressed with their language
skills in some places it's a
bureaucratic challenge for instance Asia
is a place of a lot of languages I found
MIT people are on deployment in Thailand
and they speak Mandarin they're on
deployment in the Philippines and
they're the team speaks Korean it's hard
to match up the language with the group
but even in places where it shouldn't be
too hard like Afghanistan and Iraq
there's too little linguistic awareness
I think with the things where they can
do better it's because they have not
gotten the training so it's not really
their fault
capability to employ natives because
English is the second language is so
common what we do in a way we have like
you know we have contractors civilian
contractors who are often new American
citizens I traveled around Iraq with you
know probably the most useful person in
the marine battalion with which I
traveled was a civilian American
Palestinian who on one occasion saved
our lives because we were driving along
towards a bridge and an older rocky man
said said said in Arabic very quickly
don't cross the bridge don't cross the
bridge and the Palestinian translator
jumped off spoke to him and he stopped
the convoy I was riding in the first
Humvee it turned out to be a daisy-chain
of improvised explosive devices on the
bridge that they had to send out a squad
you know to defuse and when they blew it
it was so intense that a mile away we
felt the air pressure against us um the
problem is we don't have enough of these
people there are there are some
bureaucratic problems with security
clearances and concerns which generally
I don't go along with because I believe
you play percentages even if one out of
a hundred has a problem you still get
nine you know you still get 99 other
people the Marines have tried and they
are trying to recruit from will call
them exotic immigrant communities in the
US more and more because another the
second most useful person in this marine
battalion was the Lance Corporal an
American a Syrian immigrant to
California who still didn't have a
citizenship but he sat in on some of the
most classified conversations with the
Iraqis because he was the only one who
spoke Arabic and so he was the go-to guy
he was working from 6:00 a.m. to
midnight he was a Lance Corporal only
left Syria two or three years ago and so
the Marines have been trying to recruit
more of these kinds of people but they
told me I you know I was speaking
speaking to just - some - some Marines
the other day and
they said they're having trouble it's
not the easiest thing yeah yeah and I
heard the chaplains office say that one
of the their big concerns is that the
divorce rate has jumped 73 percent is
what they said in one year
I'm the military in the Army in the Army
and that includes the Guard and Reserve
which aren't particularly concerned
about but they didn't give any more
numbers than that and they didn't say
they said the percentage but they didn't
say what it was from have you been
seeing that effect when you've been
embedded and has what kind of effect
does that have on morale well obviously
when you have guard Guardsmen and
reservists who who kind of assumed
they're gonna be deployed for a month
and are serving 10 or 11 months it's
going to put a lot of pressure on family
life so that's very intuitive kind of
with speck Green Berets are a special
community they tend to be in their 30s
they tend quite a few of them have been
divorced once or more so and but for
them that's an old story it's it's
nothing new and since I'm not gonna get
til the regular army till vol 2
basically all I can talk about is the
Green Berets and the Marines are too
young really because most Marines are in
their early 20s but especially among the
guard at the guardsmen and the Green
Berets they're you know many most are
you know had at least one divorce but
again that was nothing new yeah
preparing that the house representatives
um I I think that you made great an
interesting point about the language
barrier I was also wondering if you
found any sort of lacking in cultural
awareness or sensitivity or religious
awareness since we're getting into an
age of cultural and religious wars so I
wasn't sure if you had any comment on
that the troops are given like training
pamphlets about all this stuff but it's
it's very very rudimentary well one
thing I did learn about you know again
back to breaking stereotypes is that on
an individual basis evangelical
Christians and I met quite a few of them
and you know in the court you know in
the course of my work we're if anything
less hostile more understanding more
culturally interested in Muslim culture
religion etc that then than the other so
I don't see a problem on an individual
basis with that I just didn't see it
based on your experiences in the last
several years if you were to rewind and
play this forward again
what should the US military have done in
the conduct of its war in Iraq or was
there anything it could have done
differently that would have terminated
the war in less costly um
the years I've been writing that in
order to avoid tragedy you have to think
tragically and that it's good to be a
constructive pessimist the US military
the Department of Defense worse-case did
the original invasion of Iraq and it got
as a consequence the best possible
result it seemed to have best case to
dis stabilization and occupation and got
the worst possible result
I say worst possible result because if
you read the Marines wall small war
manual of 1938 it sort of defined
success in an invasion by the failure of
an insurgency to spring up afterwards
and it warns against winning too quickly
because if you win too quickly the enemy
isn't so much to feed it as disperses
into small groups links up with criminal
gangs and other what the manual calls
antisocial forces and then comes back at
you to attack the new authorities in
small numbers now that's kind of of just
a basically a description uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
of where we're at now if I had to say
anything different there's been a lot of
debate in writing about we needed more
numbers and this and that obviously I
won't get into that but one thing I
would do is I would have wished that the
victory that the victory would have been
chipped slower not faster that we would
have gone rather than avoided places we
would have gone right into them we sort
of circled around Fallujah Ramadi we
went straight to Baghdad and declared
the victory I wish it would have taken
us a bit longer and it was a bit more
thorough
yeah yeah one more question after this
okay
yeah Christine mission accom with
American University and I have a
two-part question as well building on
what you were just saying I would be
curious what your idea of what security
would actually look like in a
humanitarian mission or in a
post-conflict situation and also given
your description and it appears that the
military would be essentially assuming a
lot of the work done by development
agencies in the NGO community and I was
just wondering what role if any you
would see for the NGO community in the
future and how that relationship would
work all right first of all in the
Philippines during Operation Enduring
Freedom Philippines when first Special
Forces Group went into the Sulu
Archipelago to root out Abu Sayyaf and
Jim Islamia guerrillas but without
firing a shot by winning over the local
population through humanitarian and
veterinary exercises they define success
by establishing enough security so that
civilian international organizations
could come into that area and relieve
them that's how they define success Bret
you know them themselves being replaced
by civilian relief agencies in this case
with Taiwan based NGOs that employed a
local of Filipinos the u.s. Navy has a
plan US Navy has two hospital ships the
hope and the mercy I believe and one of
the plans or ideas is to permanently
embed NGOs on those ships to have
permanent offices that you know and
equipment and the US Navy would provide
the transport the sea lifts etc to have
local NGOs I believe that one of the
problems here is that the US military
and the NGO community are very there
they are cultures in conflict in a way
frankly one is conservative one is
liberal one is very nationalistic one is
more thinks in terms of international
society NGOs a very eye
the holistic they're also very tough
I've seen them spend weeks and months in
the poorest African villages and
situations where many American soldiers
wouldn't be but I've seen meetings where
you can really see the tension and yet
the future is not just interagency
within the US government its combined
operations with NGOs and I think and the
US military I don't think I don't see
the US military replacing NGOs in any
way what I do see though is in this in
sudden disasters the Millett US military
will get in first and in places where
the security is too fragile for civilian
NGOs to be led in by their own head
offices the US military will fill the
gap or other militaries the German or
French or whatever when I said the
militarization of relief aid I didn't
just mean the US military because
actually the Canadians are very active
around the world even though they didn't
go to Iraq one more question
it's very hard to understand from the
reporting of the newspapers and
television what's happening in Iraq in
terms of the war if I might ask two
questions of you what have you learned
about the way the insurgents see what's
happening that is both the rank-and-file
in so far as you can find out about the
leadership some have been captured for
instance and secondly how do the
experienced army professionals on the
ground see what's happening ah the only
since I haven't covered the insurgent
side there's been a lot of good
reporting work done by Patrick Graham a
Canadian journalist and others I can't
tell you what insurgents think what I
can tell you is that insurgents learn in
many ways faster than the US military
because of their own email network which
is not subject to bureaucratic
formalities like ours are although you
do have you know a lot of informally
email networks at the captain and major
level but the insurgents communicate
changes in American tactics very fast
among themselves among US military
officials I can tell you what they've
told me is the problem is less and less
military in Iraq its governance and
institutions there isn't that much
combat in Iraq on the US isn't losing
any combat sorties the question is can
the constitutional process progress is
messily is it you know even in a very
messy way consider war be prevented can
the new Iraqi army be stood up not to a
point where it can operate on its own
but we're at the company level it can
operate well with two or three American
invite advisors embedded in it can the
car bombs be kept to a statistically
tactically you know almost meaningless
level when you consider that it is a
country of 23 million people and can you
get them down to a point where Iraq may
drift from page 1 to page 3 to page 5
but when you ask high-level officers
about what they think about Iraq they
say the morale of our troops is fine
we're doing fine it's a governor
constitutional political challenge at
this point my pleasure my pleasure thank
you Robert Kaplan writes for The
Atlantic Monthly Magazine Imperial
grunts the American military on the
ground is published by Random House on
the web at Random House dot-com